oui chef oui chef
ça marche ça marche i couverte les
caviars en appuyant la mairie d'olemps
du site
augusta sur trois pièces
une fébrilité sur mon film
foie gras chaud crème garantie j'en suis
un bouge aux épices un plan sur roxy
voyais poker d'agneau
pas d'annuaire
grenier
et encore plus à l'est qui fait ça
quand c'est bon il ya pas meilleur
savez que quand c'est bon il n'ya pas
meilleure et vous ne savez pas
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un jour
exceptionnel c'est la 100e émission de
cette production culinaire que le monde
entier nous envie
ça fait trois ans que vous nous
supporter merci de votre patience merci
de votre attention
vous avez reconnu tous les amis qui sont
au générique vous avez adrian gazin dit
la vieille ma chérie bonjour enfin sur
ma vie que tu sois là il n'est pas vieux
mais il est jeune gens gagnent rien
d'autre pour me sentir tout ouïe josiane
le fait qu'il semblait ne serait que les
centièmes par tous
merci devient jamais 98e vous pouvez
vous savoir d'une 100e
on a une chance folle joël rebuchon on
ne présente plus jeunes rue du champ
tout le monde a dit que c'était le plus
grand cuisinier français je crois que
c'est vrai j'aimerais peut l'encourager
je suis normal le père tranquille il est
pas vraiment très tranquille ces gens
nourris gâte 30 avenue du maine c'est un
tout petit bistrot car dans cette
émission
toutes les cuisines ont été représentés
depuis gilbert qui est caché derrière
gilbert isaac de la fermette marbeuf
il est là tout timide il se planque il
est dans une très belle maison tenue par
mon ami jean laurent dans un décor
naturel qui datent de 1900 et puis il
n'ya pas de gâteau sans pâtissier pour
ce gâteau pour ce gâteau anniversaire
car c'est un gâteau anniversaire comme
vous pouvez le constater michel gavillon
de la maison dalloyau gavillon nous
sommes un petit jeune qui est là aussi
qui s'appelle benoît et qui ne quitte
jamais son chef de la production
eh bien nous allons partager ensemble
cette soir cet après midi pas tout de
suite un michel parce que je crois que
nous sommes là quand même invité les
spectateurs pour faire une petite
recette à la veille de la saint
sylvestre
il faut casser la croûte jambes vous
êtes d'accord bien sûr surtout qui fait
des choses simples vraiment facile
exactement ça adrienne a déclaré forfait
la la migraine elle rentre de croisière
allen mine radieuse elle veut pas faire
la cuisine
jean lui ne fait que des terrines il
paraît que les terrines pour la saint
sylvestre gens ça colle pas
mais je crois que je vais aller aux
restos du coeur eh ben on va aller au
resto du coeur c'est une belle formule
aussi également gilbert ne veut rien
faire alors le sort a désigné pour
cuisiner joël rebuchon merci joël
d'avoir accepté c'est vraiment très
gentils et puis benoît alors genre
vous invite dans notre cuisine donc dans
celles des téléspectateurs c'est une
super production la cuisine est là elle
est superbement installé il ya plein de
victuailles
c'est formidable joël qu'est ce que vous
allez nous préparer c'est agents gagnent
que vous faites la cuisine
ben écoutez comme ça d' approche des
fêtes donc c'est des huîtres chaudes au
curry et au fenouil
mais ben oui alors donc ont choisi
d'isoler le titre c'est de la veine que
je dise oui quand c'est bon il ya pas
meilleur oui c'est sûr la reine il était
il à ses conseils supérieurs de lui trop
chaude française a c'est exactement ce
l'agencé la chambre syndicale de la
haute cuisine mais ils ont déménagé il
ya eu 1 qu'il ya eu un putsch le
président a été dégommé et voilà ils ont
débaptisé on se fait pour soi mais oui
exactement vous faites la cuisine à la
maison
oui qu'est ce que vous faites cette
recette secrète aux cheveux pleins de
trucs généralement enfin quand j'ai pas
beaucoup de temps je rentre tard mais je
fais des huîtres chaudes au curry choix
oui très bien ben justement vers les
matins de sabots déjà beau j'ai réduit
des sales gosses avait fermé sa bonne
recette
j'ai connu jean il ya quelques années
c'était un grand silence d'un instrument
qui a disparu et qui s'appelait le sabot
de noces au vote d'anvers au curry voilà
au curry c'est un peu dur mais il faut
laisser cuire très longtemps c'est comme
le corbeau fera non recettes des invités
pendant génie pour y ait un grand grande
casserole vous mettez un corbeau et
enfin vous mettez des petits légumes
vous faites une nage et où vous mettez
un corbeau et un fer à repasser
oui et quand le fer à repasser et move
vous pouvez manger le corbeau c'est une
bonne recette
vous savez ce qu'on appelle le corbeau
actuellement non ce sont des bécasses
est ce que vous savez on en parlera
devant des bécasses dans le restaurant
on appelle ça le corps que je quitterais
très facile à faire aussi vous prenez
une poutre oui et vous la couper en
petits carrés et vous la mettez à retire
avec un canard fait du canard aux
solides
très bien je crois qu'il faut bosser
messieurs travailler c'est pas le fond
qui vous manque le plus parce que il
n'ya pas pondre ce genre vous allez
passer plus dans ma salle à manger
je vais passer la hausse et elle est
très belle bien sûr c'est la mignonne
qu'on a transporté pour l'installer ici
bas et le jeu c'est formidable c'est un
jeune designer qui voulait installer
régis do they do we qui fait des choses
très très jolie regardez par exemple ce
poivrier que oui merveille et en février
d'un nouveau modèle qui tout à fait
design d'un côté les siens de l'autre le
parent et surtout ses boucles d'or des
boucles d'oreilles qui sont vraiment
formule c'est sûr que la peur du tout
rire que c'est très bien avec votre
salama en prénationale vous savez dans
la cuisine la salamandre joue un rôle
très important pour donner un petit coup
de chaud oui on boit une petite goutte
comme ça ce n'est pas de refus
parce que vous savez les verts même
s'ils sont très très beau quand ils sont
vides ce triste comme des jeux fait très
mal mon service parce que vous savez que
je dois goûter le charme d'un gris quoi
que ce soit oui des fois qu'ils soient
piégés non apparemment nos preuves et
vous pouvez déguster ce joli ce qui fait
ce petit jeu la main ayant vu remis dans
les fleurs derrière son de la maison
trousselier away we go ce nom c'est des
vrais vous avez perdu j'ai envoyé vous
avez cru que c'était des fausses mais
pas du tout comme nous avons beaucoup de
moyens nous avons accepté des fleurs
fraîches c'est plutôt chez qui c'est
très joli alors on en laisse peut-être
ce petit mozart on peut pas ce décor et
non les ont déjà joël tout va bien tu
vas tout se passe bien pour le moment
nous devons nous garder en vie vous nous
dites quand même ce que vous faites un
je vais aller les surveiller de près
parce qu'on ne sait jamais je voudrais
pas que alors le jeu consiste à ouvrir
les huîtres
oui alors on leur a ouvert les yeux et
on enlevait les coquilles ont donc là on
a mis du beurre avec un demi oignon le
quart d'un bulbe de fenouil le quart
d'un bulbe attention nous sommes en
période de fêtes et si vous mettez le
vu le banquier ça fait augmenter le prix
qu'on est en train de le faire suer et
la 18e donc on a mis de l'échalote le
vin blanc
et le beurre et on a reversé le jus sur
les 8 es en train de juste de cuir les
huit combien les dentelles juste à
frémissement et ses cuirs sont une porte
très peu la cuisson dès que cette île
c'est chaud c'est cuit et alors ça crée
en quelques minutes à peine le chagrine
voilà maintenant à son plus elles sont
cuites
alors on les lots dont les le garde au
chaud elles vont continuer d'offrir non
non on va les garder au chaud et on va
finir la sauce pendant ce temps des gens
est ce que vous avez une question à
poser à joël robuchon qui est prêt à
vous répondre d'ailleurs j'ai pas suivi
dans l'ordre à l'europarlement télé pour
commencer on a compris je pense que nos
amis téléspectateurs n'ont pas compris
moi j'ai pas compris personne ne
comprend on est bien d'accord
alors on recommence tout on efface on
commence en mai un petit pot de beurre
on met un peu de curry maintenant il va
nous redonner tous à la fonte
oui le curry regardez c'est de l'ordre
de curer une pointe de curry le curry ce
oui c'est bernanos le journal d'un curé
de campagne
avec ce bon curry d'ailleurs qui vient
de je crois d'une de quelle région ça
vient le curry joël pour savoir si vous
êtes aussi calé qu'on veut bien nous le
dr du périgord ceux du périph voilà la
curie du périgord lycée des cochons qui
font des trucs dans la terre n'en
parlera tout à l'heure on a un produit
du périgord on a c'est formidable pour
jean yanne uniquement pour jean oui oui
pour les autres ça ne suis pas capable
de la faire c'est vrai bon alors là on a
tous les ingrédients qui sont notés
gentil au cas où nous avons oublié
quelque chose on peut toujours se faire
un peu de lecture comme à la chapelle
sixtine allons-y lyon peut pas appeler
le minitel bas si on peut aussi appeler
le minitel si vous n'avez pas pu noter
vous tapez notre minitel 36 15 pick 3
vous aurez la recette de jean yanne et
de son chef de cuisine car joël robuchon
vient d'abandonner son restaurant de la
rue blanche en février à la maison voilà
il fallait que
cette information à peine le public
parce que ils s'ennuient un jeune loup
vous ennuyer rue de longchamp travail à
écouter on va commencer c'est un bon pas
très je crois on a parlé déjà fixé les
dates
j'habite à côté mode tout est alors je l
ai une grande spécialité ce sont les
nouilles au gras beaucoup de grains et
pas beaucoup de nouilles
dites-nous quand même ce que vous faites
joël vallat choix pas de finir la chose
donc maintenant allez allez donc le
fenouil le poireau qui a étudié dans le
beurre j'ai mis le jus 18 la pression
des 8 avec un petit peu de vin blanc et
maintenant j'apporte à tout petit peu de
beurre pour émulsionner la science la
bière voilà une superbe assiette vous
savez j'en vous avez un défaut comme moi
au restaurant je crois que vous
retournez toujours les assiettes pour en
connaître la provenance de son rideau
oui évidemment puisque leur après le
drame il y en a partout
ça ce sont des assiettes en porcelaine
de limoges de la maison lafarge
spécialement destiné à gillot je ne
savais pas que lafarge spécialiste du
ciment faisait également de la
porcelaine lui aussi a dit simon qui
sont souhaite donc on peut les laisser
tomber
je viens on va commencer à dresser nous
allons commencer à dresser on dresse les
huîtres vous savez rustavi pour trouver
également dressé les 8 alors regardez ça
a vraiment qu en temps réel à mal grec
plaisantions sous le regard scrutateur
de jean yanne à qui rien n'échappe
alors il faut six huîtres par personne
joël ouais c'est parce que vous voyez ce
sont des il faut choisir toujours des
huîtres grâce à elle donc ils se
tiennent bien si les gîtes sont pas
grâce à se tiennent pas et à
disparaissent complètement à la question
est ce qu'on peut dresser les 8 août non
on peut dresser les huit on peut les en
place et c'est formidable de voir 2
travailler alors comment s'appelle que
vous l'association des autres saumons
des zooms quelques manques
combien de personnes viendront en
général on est content quand on les
mange c'est un jeu et s'il faut
commander 50 souvent qu'ils vont pas
mettre sa oui c'est vrai une période de
en période de fête quand même c'est un
peu exagéré
voilà c'est formidable on peut pas se
mettre directement dans le bras moi je
prendrais le cholestérol à perfusion en
deux fois alors regardez joël prend tout
son temps il fignole on va quand même
accéléré un tout petit peu de ce plat
est presque terminée voilà il en
manquait il ne faut pas qu'ils aient de
blanc dans l'assiette
il faut que la porcelaine soit
entièrement recouverte c'est ce que ça
vous plaise gens c'est vous qui allez
manger ça c'est un curiste c'est pour ça
c'est le curry voilà attention regardez
où la la la la la la la la
c'est un plat de concours car je vous
rappelle il a horreur que nous en
parlions
joël est un des meilleurs ouvriers de
france de cuisine ils ne sont pas
nombreux
ça lui permet de porter comme vous
pouvez le constater du bleu blanc rouge
attendait ça j'allais dire ça vous tenir
non pas du tout il n'a pas encore la
légion d'honneur et un petit peu de
ciboulette
si vous n'avez pas tous noté je vous le
rappelle vous tapez notre codes minitel
36 15 peac3 et vous pourrez avoir la
recette de joël robuchon qui est
restaurateur chez jamin rue de longchamp
thiam alors une chose mais wallon alors
joël là je crois que vous avez amené une
surprise et le jeu consiste à demander
quel est ce produit du beau jeu à qui
avoue également moi je vous interroge et
répondait si vous en avez le courage
tout ça oui c'est du son offre voilà
c'est du safran il a gagné je suis
forcément oui ça va ça vient votre chien
de race
et oui c'est un taux qui vient d'inde
oui c'est vrai ces erreurs c'est très
beau mais alors si on le met là on peut
faire le clown et ça peut faire
éventuellement faire le plus complet non
je crois qu'ils sont quand même rétablir
la vérité lorsqu'elle était l'arbitré ce
sont les premières truffes c'est la
tuber melanosporum melanosporum tuber
melanosporum dans les pros ce qui l
amène à constater son énorme parce que
c'est lui produire qu'on trouve et après
plus on avance dans la saison et
deuxième tout petit mineur et plus elle
augmente alors qu'il faut toujours faire
toute façon quand on choisit une truffe
les choisir les plus noires possible là
ce sont les premières et on a de la
chance parce que mois de décembre en
général sont encore un petit peu blanche
ce qu'il faut faire la première chose
quand on les reçoit bien sûr il faut
l'aimer cumulé en colère aussi
il faut toujours les éplucher parce que
là la peau est assez fraîches et donc il
faut toujours et on serre les parents ce
que joël ça ne passe pas en machine non
non c'est assez difficile vous savez
qu'en fin de compte tout ça dépend
l'origine il y en a qui poussent entre
les pierres il y en a qui bouge qui
pousse dans du sable donc quand ils sont
dans le sable sont garon 200 500 et
pierre à prendre la forme les pierres et
se sont parce que les meilleurs puisque
vous savez que la truffe tout ce qu'est
ce qui fait la truffe c'est le climat le
terrain et larmes
donc il faut faire en fonction de
l'arbre on aura des truffes de chaînes
qui sont sûrement les meilleurs jeunes
au but il connaît tous par coeur et de
tillé bruyère voilà joël c'est non c'est
pas les mêmes parce qu'elle tient moins
longtemps jeunes merci pour le petit
cadeau gens on va s'arranger at elle
ajouté je ne crois pas nous allons
goûter ça tout de suite
on va passer au gâteau et on est obligé
un parce que nos amis nous attendons ils
ont été très gentils de patienter prenez
place je vous rejoins médias croyais que
je vais manger des huîtres pro du gâteau
mois
car je crois qu'il nous manquait une
bougie pour la souffler alors
approchez-vous adrienne je vais vous
demander ma chérie de bien vouloir
souffler la bougie de cette 100e édition
on attend un tout petit moment je
voudrais remercier tous mes amis
techniciens tous mes amis réalisateurs
mon papa ma môman tous les chefs de
cuisine qui sont venus si nombreux
supporter cette émission qui n'est pas
toujours très facile à réaliser
et puis voilà c'est avec beaucoup
d'émotion que je vous donne rendez vous
à l'année prochaine
en vous souhaitant qu est-ce qu on
souhaite jean à nos amis téléspectateurs
leur souhaite de bien bon appétit bon
appétit
et puis une bonne fin d'année sans trop
d'excès on vous donnera la recette du
boulon du bouillon de volaille la
semaine prochaine adrienne on souffle en
simple ça y est c'est fait mais michel
vous avez parlé logis qui se partage
voilà c'est michel seyt votre dur métier
et voilà vous avez besoin de champagne
[Musique]